ayoh really hot boyfriend check welcome
to my new favorite video on the internet
yes it's obviously a tick-tock featuring
John Stamos and david dobrik doing that
whole really hot boyfriend check things
and don't worry if that video is too
short for you John also posted his own
version heyo
really hot boyfriend check that
starburst moment I might never get over
it ok anyways David and John's bromance
actually goes way back
John was featured in this 2017 vlog of
David's literally titled we found out
where John Stamos lives
thank you John Stamos
my name's Jason I'm David huge hair is
even better in person
yeah and David even visited the full
House house with John in 2018 I just got
done it when I was your age I got a
broken heart - I got dumped you got
dumped - no now we know David watches
our et videos yep we saw your tick-tock
David David you're right and not as a
beer house and we just want to say we
stand and while we think things with you
and Madison are platonic we're also
living for the dick talks with other
tick-tock errs like Charlie
and Addison hey Addison Helen let me
give a different angle
all right go right now I have 14 million
on tick tock and I have almost 4 million
on Instagram yeah it's crazy what is
your family make of all of this um so my
family is so supportive of me like
luckily well that was so casual I really
wanted to give you an opportunity to
clarify who your best friends are I know
this has been I'm gonna get congrats
woven wrap who my best friends are you
know I'm gonna plead the fifth
all right guys that's it for today for
all the latest on David and John and
well tick-tock stick with all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye
for now
[Music]